so first of all we spent much of the
year talking about the cop 26 climate
summit in glasgow which happened of
course last month but another un meeting
due to take place in kunming in china is
now in danger of being delayed for the
fourth time due to the rapid spread of
the latest covert variant
at stake is a deal to safeguard
ecosystems so are we in danger of
forgetting the importance of
biodiversity actually what do you think
how important is it that this kunming
summit goes ahead do you
think recruitment is is pivotal
the fact that it's been postponed again
uh even after it was made primarily
online last year kind of gives away the
impression that uh the ambitions that we
have the biodiversity have frankly
crashed through the floor
we can't allow the the broader issue of
how our ecosystems function to be
overshadowed by uh politics convenience
and a tendency to focus on the headline
issues of carbon rather than the broader
natural systems within
our chili you're like your line just
throws that promote i'm going to move
over to jen but i will come back to you
and hopefully it'll revive itself but
jen do you agree with that i mean the
world hasn't done brilliantly on meeting
biodiversity targets that were set in
japan in 2010 so how important is this
summit and what does need to be done
this summit is very important it's as
important as glasgow it's as important
as any other major meeting where
countries set rules for themselves that
they have to follow
they didn't do a great job the last time
they set rules and targets for nature
they didn't fully meet any of the
targets so kunming is very important
it will go ahead it'll be postponed
partly because there was a meeting
that's supposed to happen before the cop
it was postponed because of worries
about omicron and there has to
procedurally be a bit of time between
that meeting and the cops so
could being i think is still very much
on the cards still going to happen it's
just a bit of a delay hopefully just for
procedural reasons
and chilly expand a little bit more on
why you think it's important to tackle
both biodiversity and climate change
together
thank you very much for that
biodiversity is the broader picture it's
our ecosystem it's our home it's our
planet it's the very land we stand on
the air we breathe the decarbonization
priorities of the corp process are a
subset of biodiversity so if we don't
get that biodiversity right we can't get
carbon uh
sequestration right in it in a holistic
continuous and sustainable way uh even
though coptic
a6 gets all headlines uh the actual
broader natural systems in which we sit
deserve just as much or even more
attention
your system is playing he's teasing us
we're getting dramatic pauses
occasionally but we are getting the gist
of what you're saying uh jen very
briefly and is it easier in some ways
for people to relate to the whole nature
issue
than climate change
i think so we walk through nature we see
nature we hear nature it's all around us
all the time
the climate system is invisible in a way
you know we sort of get inklings here
and there and hints that maybe climate's
changing but it's often in numbers and
models and figures
but nature we know you know we have a
deep connection with nature going back
to poetry and stories from our ancestors
way way back so
i think people do understand the need to
protect nature and they get behind that
sort of action